mais je voudrais quand même insisté sur
le fait que notre vocation la vocation
de cette commission denquête c'est
vraiment de comprendre de comprendre
pourquoi ces derniers temps il y a eu un
recours en augmentation des cabinets de
conseil privé sur des missions qui nous
semble quand même importante et nous
voulons comprendre parce que
comprendre ça a peut supposer que un
certain nombre de d'éléments qui nous
paraissent opaque puisse être levé et
gagner surtout en transparence
à la demande de la commission d' enquête
le ministère a transmis dont vous l'avez
dit l'ensemble des livrables des
cabinets de conseils pendant la crise
sanitaire et sincèrement nous vous en
remercions
toutefois leur lecture donne quand même
le vertige
car elle les montre une intervention
massive de ces cabinets sur tous les
pans de la crise sanitaire et sur des
missions qui nous semblait relever de
l'administration est donc là nous avons
l'exemple d'un livrables de ma cuisse
est en date du 23 août 2000 21 qui fait
un bilan des injections vaccinales
réalise à cette date qui établit des
projections sur la vaccination pour
atteindre la cible de 50 millions de
primo vaccination que le gouvernement
s'était fixé en septembre
2021 de première question est simple
c'est quel a été le rôle de mckinsey
dans l'établissement de ses projections
vaccinale par exemple en septembre 2021
est dans la même logique deuxième
question ce document de mckinsey a été
transmis au conseil de défense sanitaire
le 23 août 2021 et cette information
figure d'ailleurs noir sur blanc ou
jaune et noir sur fond jaune
sur le document donc ces documents de
mckinsey outils lüthi est qu'il était
utilisé par le conseil de défense pour
préparer ces décisions sinon pourquoi
les transmettre et vous pouvez
comprendre là encore monsieur le
ministre que cette question est
importante car conseil de défense à
interroger et interroge encore sur son
périmètre et sur ses missions je vous
remercie pour vos réponses
je vous réponds volontiers s'agit pas
d'un livrables documents que vous
montrez on en a beaucoup et
effectivement des comme celui-ci
renouveler très régulièrement j'avais
un tableau de bord j'ai toujours tableau
de bord sur lequel sont aimantés des
documents qui permettent de rendre
compte de façon très visuelle est très
rapide de la progression de la campagne
vaccinale de l'utilisation des
consommables des perspectives
d'utilisation des consommables des
commandes éventuels qui compile les
sondages et enquêtes d'opinion pour
savoir jusqu'où on peut monter dans la
vaccination quels sont les leviers et a
donc moi j'ai besoin d'avoir ce visuel
qui permet d'avoir
la crise est très vaste en terme
d'action et de de connaissances à
acquérir et et actualisée au quotidien
ce ne sont pas des livrables pardonnez
moi ce sont des documents internes au
ministère qui relève des équipes du
ministère et auquel mckinsey a participé
donc ce ne sont pas des documents
estampillés mckinsey que le cabinet de
conseil nous livrerait tel quel non ce
sont des documents qui sont ils sont
dans les équipes et donc ce sont des
documents des équipes du ministère qui
sont
estampillés ministère des solidarités de
la santé
tu du renfort d'équipés il ne se
substitue pas et vous avez parlé de la
prise de décision à aucun moment
mckinsey de m'a fait prendre une
décision en lien avec la crise sanitaire
et où la campagne vaccinale féministes
même si ce document n'est pas un
livrable
donc un document interne au ministère
sur lequel est intervenu maquis ne sais
si j'ai bien compris c'est quand même un
document qui a été transmis au conseil
de défense pourquoi c'est un document du
ministère de la santé produit par les
équipes du ministère de la santé qui
sont derrière des documents que si vous
nous vous permettons de vous les livre
et vous vous permettez de les montrer
qu'ils ne sont pas des documents qui
sont classés une classifiés et qui porte
sur des données transparentes public
nous rendons public très régulier et
monsieur nice vous nous permettrez nous
aussi nous interroger sur l'intervention
de makeen c'est sûr c'est beaucoup même
si je le répète vous nous dites que
c'est un document interne au ministère
de l'intérieur
le sens de votre question jour de leurs
formules et parce que comme on est en
commission denquête j'ai besoin de
vraiment comprendre vous nous avez dit
que ces documents que se remontre est un
document qui a été réalisé par les
services du ministère oui madame
ma question est simple est-ce que mc
kinsey est intervenu sur l'élaboration
de ce document mckinsey faisait à
renforcer l'ensemble des équipes en
charge de la politique vaccinale est
donc ce n'est pas un document mckinsey
êtes un homme et j'ai bien précisé que
ces documents du ministère et s et
michael sont intervenus je vous réponds
que mckinsey a contribué à ces documents
donc il est intervenu
constaté aucun problème avec sa
famille sont à préciser un petit peu les
choses qu'on ait fait on est en
commission denquête il faut que les
définitions soient précises on entend
bien
la société mckinsey a participé à
l'élaboration du document mais dans quel
cadre à ce moment là parce que
normalement quand on passe une un
contrat avec une société de conseil on
lui confie une mission quelle qu'elle
remplit de façon satisfaisante ou pas
c'est l'administration qui apprécie mais
vous nous dites là que ces gens là
étaient en renfort donc c'était est-ce
que c'était simplement une prestation de
complément ou est ce qu'il y avait une
commande précise un mac kinsey
d'abord là on parle d'une situation qui
est absolument exceptionnelle bon
d'accord on parle pas d'une situation du
quotidien des situations exceptionnelles
où chaque jour et même parfois même
plusieurs fois par jour on a eu besoin
de faire le point sur combien de
seringue et sont disponibles dans tel
centre combien de dispositifs nous
disent nous avons encore en stock dans
les locaux de santé publique france
combien de vaccination ont été réalisés
sur la journée d'hier avec des
répartition régionale est ce qu'on voit
des disparités étaient à grains qu'on
brasse une foule de données qui sont
d'ailleurs des données pour qui pour la
plupart sont rendus accessibles en open
data et documents que vous montrez sont
des documents qui rendent compte de
façon visuelle de tout ou partie des
indicateurs dont nous disposons ces
documents sont réalisés par les équipes
du ministère et nous avons eu besoin
dans cette période de campagne vaccinale
de renforcer les effectifs de nos
équipes par des prestataires issus de ce
cabinet de conseil qui sont venus avec
leurs propres compétences renforcer les
équipes donc on n'est pas dans un pour
ça que je fais vraiment la distinction
nous n'avons pas demandé au cabinet
privé mckinsey de bien avoir la d'avoir
la gentillesse de réaliser des documents
que nous fournirions conseil de défense
nous avons demandé du renfort rh des
équipes de mckinsey pour venir en appui
de nos propres équipes internes
participé à la mise en exergue de tous
ces enjeux logistique c'est vraiment de
ce talent t-il cette hantise c'est à j 7
sondés
vraiment durement logistiques donc c est
ce qu'on va trouver dans les documents
qui nous sont transmis la commande
précise pour ceux la situation que vous
évoquez un instant et ce sont des
commandes qui sont internes et donc nous
avons des ressources humaines que nous
avons intégré à nos équipes pour une
durée donnée pour des missions données
dans le cadre de la campagne vaccinale
quand je vous dis que nous avons eu des
renforts externe qui venait parfois
d'ailleurs lorsque si vous voulez quand
on a fait venir des généraux tiens où je
voudrais vous parler d'eux j'étais allé
une fois sorties publiques france pour
le cellule vaccinale non cellule masquer
la cdu des masques j'ai parlé avec des
officiers de gendarmerie qui était en
tenue et qui était ta santé publie
france ce sont des gens qui sont venus
avec leurs compétences et qui sont venus
renforcer nos effectifs parce que nous
avons nous avions besoin de compétences
logistiques pour pouvoir nous appuyer
sur des missions précises je vous
rappelle d'urgence éminente qu'il y
avait à fournir des masques au maximum
dans les territoires elle est déclinée
est allé chercher en chine etc vous
aviez la des compétences dans un non pas
un melting-pot parce que vous allez mal
prendre le leterme s'était pas le
s'était pas c'est tout était très
structuré et organisé
mais nous avions donc des renforts de
compétences précises dont nous avions
besoin certaines venaient du secteur
public du secteur privé certaines de
cabinet de conseil en renfort dans le
cas de la campagne vaccinale sont les
équipes de mckinsey qui sont venus en
renfort compléter les équipes internes
au ministère
jeu j'espère avoir répondu notre cadence
est ma question par été totalement
factuel et ce qu'on a dans les pièces
qui nous sont transmis la commande qui
correspond à cette prestation
il ya des contrats si les contrats nous
sont transmis on les examinera pour
comprendre mieux mais je voudrais je
voudrais revenir sur la question de la
décision évidemment honda temps non pas
à une autre réponse de la part d'un
responsable public qui prend l'appui
d'un cabinet de conseil pour
répondre à une situation que de
revendiquer la décision qui en décolle
et tous vos collègues qui sont passés
avant vous en ont fait de même ça va de
soi maintenant c'est tout ce que la
situation les situations sont beaucoup
plus compliquées que que cette
présentation un peu binaire des choses
parce que les éléments qu'on vous
transmets
contiennent déjà des éléments
d'orientation plus ou moins subtiles
nous avons par exemple dans les les
éléments que vous avez transmis hier
relevé une note du 27 octobre 2020
prégnant préparé par le cabinet roland
berger heures et qui porte sur la dispo
distribution de gants médicaux du stock
stratégique de la france ya trois
scénarios qui seront proposés je passe
les détails je vais directement la
conclusion de la note les options 2 et 3
ne permettent pas d'envisager une
reconstitution du stock stratégique
avant 2021 à font perdurer un système où
les acteurs bénéficie d'une distribution
de sécurité de l'état sans que celle ci
soit de nature à les inciter à l'arrêté
de s'approvisionner par eux mêmes votre
arbitrage est sollicité sur le choix de
l'option à privilégier
mais ce qui a vraiment un arbitrage
politique à faire quand on a une telle
démonstration
préalable le consultant ferme les portes
à la porte à deux des trois scénarios
donc il vous reste simplement à bénir le
troisième
que je me fasse bien comprendre que le
consultant proposent ce type de
raisonnement peut le suivre mais il me
semble qu'il ya une couche interposés
quand même avant la décision publique et
celle de votre administration
qui doit rédiger ces éléments tandis que
là ils vous sont plus sombres que ces
éléments vous a été présentée
directement et se trouvait le confondant
pas du tout
tout passe par le filtre de la direction
générale de la santé lorsque savoir la
direction générale de la santé donc le
nom aucune transmission directe jamais
eu à vous connaître une note transmise
directement d'un cabinet de conseil
jusqu'à mon bureau en vue de valider une
option ou une autre n'ont par ailleurs
je me permets de vous dire que si je
m'étais arrêté et là je ne parle pas de
cabinet de conseil mais par définition
de ma propre administration si j'avais
fait à chaque fois le choix enfin je
n'ai je pas fait à chaque fois le choix
kim était guidé par une administration
qu on ne va pas un cabinet de conseil
une administration il m'est arrivé de
faire des choix qui était différent que
les options qui était présenté comme
l'option qu'il fallait retenir c'est
d'ailleurs le propre du politique que
d'être capable de prendre des arbitrages
qui contreviennent parfois à l'esprit
général du corps administratif non pas
pour les embêter ou non pas pour des
raisons obscures mais parce qu'on
considère que l'acceptabilité de telle
ou telle décision
n'est pas aussi d'être que cela quand on
sera tous d'accord sur ce point là
monsieur ministre bien la question et
vous y avez répondu je leur ai vendu
j'ai pas de notre cabinet de conseil sur
mon bureau avec la messe et ne
parviennent pas directement ils sont
systématiquement retraite non seulement
ils sont retraités par l'administration
mais ensuite elles sont retraitées par
mon cabinet et ensuite un bon directeur
de cabinet et quand une note il revient
sur mon bureau pour arbitrage elle a
déjà été avisés en général vous allégez
imparable vrai que vous avez apporté 1
vous avez un parent avec la colonne et
les deux plusieurs colonnes celles à
venir quelques expériences de ces six
convois la celle des dates de signature
je le dis pour les français qui nous
regardent des dates de signature par tel
ou tel membre du cabinet ya la liste des
3 4 5 6 personnes vous avez dans la
première liste ensuite vous ouvrez vous
avez d'abord la lettre qui vous est
adressée par directeurs
d'administrations qui explique pourquoi
lui et propose un arbitrage puis vous
avez la note de votre cabinet qui vous
guider pour vous heureux pour vous
permettre de faire le juste choix et
enfin vous avez un document que vous
pouvez signer ou sur la page de
couverture du paraphe vous mettez vue et
c est cet envoyé voilà comme ça regardez
vous montrer des trucs je montre aussi
ça c'est par exemple le dossier en vue
de l'audition vous imaginez bien qu'elle
a été préparée été préparé donc elle a
été visée en date du 2 par mon directeur
de cabinet en date du 1er par ma
conseillère spéciale à visée par le
directeur de cabinet adjoint
et elle a été réalisée par mon
conseiller parlementaire qui est ici
présents hier même plus une petit à
petit mot tda c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne et donc je n'ai jamais dansé
par à plat regardez la moindre note d'un
cabinet de conseil tel n'existe pas
à l'homme le rapporteur
monsieur minutes mais encore vous poser
une question sur un deuxième exemple
mais tout ça c'est sur la base des
documents que nous avons reçus n'avons
rien inventé
on a on à la fois satisfait à votre
demande et la fois on a bien conscience
que vous envoyez des milliers de pages
de documents
c'est aussi l'assurance de pouvoir se
noyait donc je serais très heureux pour
exaucer sortie en soi n'est sorti donc
là allez on est un petit peu en arrière
on né le 8 juillet 2021 d'accord soit
quatre jours avant l'intervention du
président de la république donc le 12
juillet pour annoncer donc la
vaccination obligatoire des soignants et
l'extension du pass sanitaire au lieu de
loisirs et de culture met d'accord
jusqu'à donc
mackinsey encore lui aurait dit vous
allez me dire que c'est peut-être parce
à un livrable intitulé qui hélas
sécurisé l'objectif de 40 millions de
vaccinés et à fin août d'accord comment
ça quand même la porte en soirée tout de
suite quel est le logo qui est sur le
document
on est ici dans une collision sérieux
ce qui est marqué mckinsey quelque part
dans depuis maria paz et mac si les
marques et quel logo ministère donc non
c'était pas un livrable de mckinsey êtes
un terme à ce qu'on appelle le cabinet
colline où la task force vaccinale qui
relève directement de mon autorité au
sein du ministère d'accord je veux qu'on
soit très précis alors messieurs dans
ces cas là on va être très précis et je
vais l'est
il y à une note sais pas si je vais la
retrouver voilà une note halak qui a été
rédigé à l'administration à l'attention
de monsieur le directeur général de la
santé objet planification de la
dissolution de la cellule de
coordination interministérielle
logistique et moyens sanitaires cci
s
cette note a été rédigée par deux
personnes
le dossier était suivi par deux
personnes dont une
qui est salariée d'un cabinet privé
et
une note aux directions une note la
direction générale de la santé peut être
rédigée par des études qui viennent en
renfort issus de cabinets privés oui
quelle vous quel est le l'étonnement
comité de répression subie ce n'est pas
dérangeant notre sens que un document
estampillé ministère des solidarités
j'avais pas fini a laissé ouvert
manifestement
la personne qui rédige cela n'est pas
trop siège de mckinsey la personne qui
rédige cela c'est le principe
pardonnez-moi du renfort de conseil
c'est une personne qui est délégué par
le cabinet en raison de ses compétences
au sein d'une équipe au sein du
ministère
c'est exact je crois que c'est la règle
en principe de conseils parce que vous
faites appel à des ressources humaine
extérieure à vos ressources humaines
internes par définition les personnes ou
les intégrer le temps de leur mission à
votre équipe oui non mais on est on est
d'accord on est d'accord sauf que vous
nous dites quand je vais vous poser ma
deuxième question que ce n'est pas un
document mike et mckinsey puisqu'il est
estampillé ministère de la solidarité de
la santé je l'entends mais on fera et
rauscher je note que vous avez demandé
faisant de vous envoyer la totalité des
documents auxquels le cabinet a plus
contribué de près ou de loin d'où
l'exhaustivité des pièces que nous avons
livré de manière à ce que nous soyons
fassions pas reprocher de ne pas avoir
eu donc c'est à dire que tout document
auquel mckinsey a contribué de près ou
de loin on nous avait envoyé si on
devait si vous nous aviez demandé la
liste était document estampillé mckinsey
présents dans le dossier vous auriez une
feuille blanche la sénatrice vous avez
là tous les documents auxquels ils ont
pu contribuer ils ont pu
contribué de près ou de loin mon titre
des renforts rh interne internaliser
dans nos équipes le temps des missions
et sans pouvoir décisionnel et sans lien
direct avec les ministres
n'a pas roulé que jérôme bascher
juste une précision que j'existe rex et
moi
à pratiquer d'administration qui est
aussi un peu longue et plutôt que
la note soit rédigée et clairement avec
un dossier suivi par l'agent qui relève
de votre responsabilité que le renfort
puisse être annexés si vous voulez et
c'est peut-être demi confusion qui peut
être perturbé maints de la reporter est
ce que vous ne trouveriez pas plus
logique de bien séparer les deux tout
simplement c'est pas donc j'ai une idée
c'est pas la vérité toute la vérité est
votre sentiment c'est toujours le cas en
temps normal ça n'est jamais ou très
rarement le cas en situation
exceptionnelle je vous avais besoin de
logisticiens ça pose pas de difficultés
quand c'est un gendarme
je vous ai dit un gendarme qui étaient
les gendarmes et des militaires intégrés
à la cellule vaccinale qui ont participé
au sein des équipes normale du ministère
à la gestion logistique ça ne gêne
personne c'est un gendarme c'est un
militaire donc et quand c'est un camp
c'est un ingénieur ou un logisticien
professionnel qui vient du privé il y
aurait une discussion je vous dis que
les règles qui permettent de se
soustraire à cette suspicion sont les
règles très claires aucun pouvoir
décisionnel des contrats passés qui sont
claires une évaluation et dans
l'attribution des marchés le suivi
strictement prévues par la loi donc je
joue pour ça que j'ai à dire j'avais dit
cette interview je vous remercie de
l'avoir cité en introduction parce que
je la revendique il ya des ressources et
des talents dans le secteur privé et des
ressources et des talents d'autres
acteurs publics quand on est en période
de crise exceptionnelle on doit mener
une campagne vaccinale tambour battant
sauf à ce que vous considériez qu'on
serait aller trop vite fait je crois que
c'était des situations début de la
campagne
vous allez chercher les compétences là
où elles sont et vous pouvez vous
enorgueillir d'avoir un beau pays dans
lequel vous trouverez de très belles
compétences diversifiées en public et en
privé là on avait juste besoin d'une
masse de gens beaucoup plus importante
que d'habitude donc on a rempli on a
gonflé les équipes avec des compétences
et des talents qui venaient de
différents secteurs mais encore une fois
les règles sont claires donc je vais
vous mettre un logo gendarmerie sur un
bout de documents parce qu'il ya un
gendarme qui a participé à la collecte
des informations qu'ont permis de
constituer le document
la france est en train de l'agent public
et salariés du privé je vous parle d'une
équipe j'ai le statut différent je
m'attendais évidemment que ce qui ce qui
fait question à la commission je vais
essayer de vous exprimer le mieux
possible qui ne fait pas partie de
l'administration comme jérôme bascher ni
de près ni de loin c'est que quand on
fait appel à des cabinets de conseils
habituellement sur la base d'un
contrôleur confie une mission et là vous
nous expliquer que vous avez intégré des
compétences à l'intérieur de vos équipes
et je vais regarder avec mes collègues
de prêts dont les contrats vous allez
nous faire suivre comment sont bordés
leurs fonctions parce que on a
l'impression la queue on appris des
agents publics entre guillemets dans un
vivier privé sans avoir
passé un marché clair sur une mission
précise avec les cabinets privés si cela
va donner ma vie c'est ça la pardonnez
moi vous sortez du cadre vous êtes en
train de conclure ou des who d'insinuer
qu'il y aurait des marchés qui ne serait
pas clair je vous répondais prouvez le
nous avons envoyé
moi qui précise les choses
une ambiguïté dans la nature des
contractions passé est dans la nature de
et dans le langage réalisation d'un
contrat qui son père allait en parle
encore une fois d'une situation
comprenait le et je suis sûr que vous le
comprenez on parle d'une situation
exceptionnelle d'extrême urgence un
présent la république dit notre pays est
en guerre nous avons besoin de
compétences nous avons besoin de talents
nous avons besoin d'aller vite tout le
monde nous demande d'aller vite les
sénateurs comme le reste des citoyens
français et tout le monde a raison de
demander d'aller très vite nous prenons
quand même évidemment la peine de
respecter les codes des marchés publics
les règles en matière de recrutement les
règles d'attribution des marchés nous
passons des contrats et nous vérifions
que les contrats sont parfaitement
limpide et nous respectons tous les
règlements en vigueur en matière
d'appels à des ressources humaines
extérieur nous internalisant nous
interdisons renforçons nos équipes avec
des personnes ressources qui proviennent
de l'extérieur du public et du privé
pour faire la guerre pour faire la
guerre il est tout à fait normal que
nous rendions des comptes nous vous
présentons la totalité des contrats des
documents auxquels de près ou de loin
les uns et les autres ont pu participer
et je réponds à vos questions mais voilà
j'ai insiste sur le fait qu'il ya je
vous le redis je suis foncièrement il
n'y a aucun moment à aucun moment un
coin de contrat ou une dérogation qui
ont été faites au fonctionnement et aux
règlements en vigueur en revanche ce qui
a changé c'est la pratique c'est à dire
que là où habituellement vous avez une
clarification des missions extérieures
avec des choses qui sont totalement
bordés est effectivement externalisés là
vous avez à l'enrichissement d'une
équipe parce que si vous devez en pe de
guerre commencé à regarder qui et à quel
endroit à la personne va préparer les
munitions et l'autre va vérifier que les
munitions sont bien transféré dans
l'arsenal vous n'allez pas vous en
sortir mais je n'ai absolument rien
insinué monsieur le ministre simplement
je vous interroger sur ce point votre
réponse est extrêmement père nous
n'avons pas encore regardé ces documents
qui nous sont parvenues hier je vous
exprimer notre
questionnement vis-à-vis de ce type de
contrat auquel nous ne sommes absolument
pas habitués jamais vu çà mau j'ai géré
quelques possessions
nous allons les examiner nous allons les
examiner nous verrons que
le ministre nous aussi nous savons qu'il
ya des compétences d'entraidé moi je
viens du privé avant d'être d'avoir
rejoint la fonction publique
territoriale
donc il ya des talents et des
compétences dans le privé que les choses
soient claires et je comprends que dans
une situation inédite de crise que nous
que nous que nous traversons nous ayons
besoin après je voulais dit au début de
mon propos ce que nous voulons nous
c'est de la transparence
[Musique]